local elections are taking place in
thanet on Thursday the 4th of May
if you aren't already on the Electoral
roll you must register to vote before
Monday the 17th of April and for the
first time you will need to bring an
accepted formal photo ID to the polling
station when you go to vote
if you want to vote at the polling
station but you don't have an accepted
form of photo ID you'll need to apply
for a voter Authority certificate before
5 PM on Tuesday the 25th of April
this video is a guide to some of the
most common forms of accepted photo ID
you can use all of the following as
photo ID
a passport issued by the UK any of the
Channel Islands the Isle of Man a
British overseas territory a country
within the European economic area or a
commonwealth country
a photographic driver's license issued
from any of the countries listed above
this includes provisional licenses
a concessionally travel pass funded by
the government or your local Authority
such as the Kent County Council Bus pass
or a disabled person's bus pass
a blue badge
a European economic area photographic ID
card or any identity card with the proof
of age standard scheme hologram also
known as a pass card or a UK biometric
residence permit
only original documents are accepted
scanned images or copies of documents
are not valid
expired documents will be accepted as
long as the photo is still a current
likeness
you can see a full list of accepted
photo ID at golf.uk forward slash how to
vote
postal voters will not be affected by
these changes they do not need to show
any form of photo ID they will be issued
with their postal ballot papers as usual
choose to vote by proxy the person whom
you have trusted to vote on your behalf
will have to take their own
identification to be issued with a
ballot paper learn more at thanet.gov.uk
forward slash voter ID
[Music]